Yeah. So when you were a kid,
you were, you were doing this,
like you've been involved. So this
is like the family business, sort of.
My family businesses, my mom's business
actually was safari businesses, so like,
like you say, sit in a land rover,
CD, animals kind of thing. Um,
and they did a little bit
of tourists walking safaris.
But then I grew up on a farm in the
outskirts of some of Harare, Zimbabwe.
And then whenever I wasn't in school,
I was on the farm run around barefoot,
catching snakes, fishing, Yada Yada.
And then when my mom wasn't booked up,
she had this little Bush plane that she
used for safaris and we'd just adventure
all over Africa. Wow. So it was
great childhood. That sounds amazing,
but fucking terrifying.
I mean,
it's like one of those things where
it's what you're used to write.
I found moving to the states at age 14
and like trying to find my place in the
world, be in this weird little
private school kid from Africa,
way more terrifying than going to meet a
tribe in the middle of the Bush, really?
For sure. Yeah. Why? Um,
like I'll give you examples.
Like I always carry a pocket knife on me,
right? My first day here in the states,
I go to school, pull my pocket,
I'm sitting in my like uniform.
So I went to a very proper English
boarding school, pull out my pocket knife,
start cutting my apple. 15 minutes
later I'm in handcuffs and I'm like,
what did I do? What did I do? I literally
had no idea what I had done wrong,
but because I had a knife at school,
everybody I had ever been to school
with had a knife to cut their apple.
Like it was the standard thing. So here
I am with like police and you know,
guns and badges and they're throwing me
in handcuffs and taking me out of the
school on day one in America.
And I'm like,
this is the scariest thing I've ever seen.
And I didn't even learn until later that
day that it was because I had a pocket
knife. And at no point did I think
having a pocket knife is a bad thing.
So they didn't tell you? No,
they just grabbed me. There
was like this whole thing,
like the knife went flying, I was chained
up and I was like, what's going on?
What's going on? And they're like, you're
in big trouble and ask why. And uh,
you know, it was like little
culture shock, things like that.
That to me where like something I'd done
everyday my whole life and now I'm like
getting thrown in Juvie for it kind of
thing. When you think back about that,
do you think that's just the consequences
of being in a large population?
For sure. Yeah. Yeah. I
mean like we, like I say,
I went to school everyday with a knife.
There was no violence issues,
there was nothing like that. But
then you come here where, you know,
the stabbings and stuff like that and
it's because, you know, we had a tie.
I lived in a tiny country
with a tiny population.
Do you think that it's possible
that I may, I mean stupid,
but there's no way you could
live like that over here. I mean,
there's no way you can have kids with a
bunch of knives. No, I don't. Culture,
I don't. Yeah, I don't think so at
all. I think that would be terrible.
And I get it now as an adult.
Nobody talked to you about it before you
left the house? No, my mom didn't know.
She's from Africa. You know, she's like,
here are your things, here's my cool.
But it might be shared. Sharpen it
before you get to tell a man. Wow.
So you were doing these always
doing these walking safaris. You,
you started out doing the driving ones
and then eventually you started doing the
walking ones? My family
business did walking's as far
as they didn't do hunting,
it was all photographic. Um, and
we were in the Zambezi valley,
so as Mbz River's one of the
biggest rivers in the world.
So we do these walking safaris and
then we did canoes safaris as well,
which is why I have so many hippo and
croc stories cause we'd be canoeing down
the Zambezi river. Um, and then taking
photographs and seeing wildlife that way.
Wow. What a crazy way to
grow up, man. It was awesome.
Your relationship to wildlife,
it's just so different than the average
person in this country. For sure.
It's very intimate. Like
I, I, I feel like I have,
like regardless of being
a scientist by trade,
I feel like I have a very intimate
understanding of animals cause I grew up
completely surrounded by them. Now
what other countries have you explored?
I'm over 60 countries now. Yeah. So a lot.
All for wildlife work.
Um,
whether it's for the show that I do or
for biology contracts before I did the
show or just because like for instance,
when I got done with college, I was like,
I had a little tiny little business
starting college, sold it and was like,
I'm going to travel the world and
try and photograph these animals.
And I went to 28 countries
looking for wildlife.